Joe how would one develop an idea first
for the webseries I mean does someone
look at what to make versus a type of
webseries that avoid that hasn't been
filled already
are you looking to fill certain
demographic industry what's popular
right now or they go off what inspires
them I would go more with the latter
with the inspiring because I I'm not a
fan of making calling cards I'm not a
fan of writing from demographics I don't
I don't think that you can think up a
story and go well that's what a 24 year
old woman who wants to buy a Volvo would
watch because that's shitty storytelling
I think write what you know is going to
be fun to write and work your ass off on
and that is going to take everything out
of you because it's got to be it's got
to be worth it's got to be fun it's got
to be worth it and I think that if you
were like I have a vampire show there
are a lot of vampire shows part of the
inspiration was to find another way into
that genre and it was part of the
thinking but I wrote a show that has
profanity in it I wrote showed that is
you know my vampire rules are know when
sparkles there's no romance it's a I
think a different approach to it but
what I I love bad guys I love crime that
whole I was a bartender in Boston had
mafia regulars so I kind of felt like I
knew a little bit about that world and
it just seemed like the perfect mix of
things so I think if you're if you're
thinking about making the shadow imagine
that there is no television industry
there is no film industry the
entertainment industry doesn't exist now
what story do you want to tell because
the only thing the entertainment
industry is going to bring you is people
telling you know people telling you what
to do people telling you what not to do
lots and lots and lots and lots of
rules and part of those rules are who's
your demographic who's going to watch
this if you're going around town trying
to get permission trying to get somebody
to say yes I think I'll do that if you
see this as the first time in the
history of storytelling that you can
create something at a quality that has
never been achievable for this price
that you can show to an audience around
the world on the Internet as not the
greatest thing in the world because so
much of this has been about yes is a
know so much of this has been about
please let me tell the story sure we're
gonna fire you now I'm bringing our
writer and our director and completely
change everything you do or what we'd
like this isn't this because it'll be
good for the sponsor all right yeah we
all want this because we can't get
sponsorship my thinking is find some way
to do it with as little as you
possibly can because the more
you have to deal with the more it slows
you down the more you're waiting for
somebody else to give you permission
it's to me it's like this is the perfect
opportunity to be able to tell stories
so I think if you can come up with a
story that you can get the cash find the
cash find somewhere around it
incorporate the budget into the idea of
the story make it make it a
consideration like when I write vampire
Bob I'm thinking about well where
where's this location while I'm writing
and if I know that location then I know
where we're gonna shoot it
I'm writing it so that's safe so much
timing and pre-production
lowers my budget we
do a lot of real issues we do a lot of
no permits use have lookouts
sometimes what we're shooting it's never
based cup of tea but I don't have a
problem with it and we've been very very
lucky a shot like 125 pages just on the
show without permits and never had a
problem but so so I think it's a
combination of thinking what story you
wanna what's there do you really want to
tell what can you afford to tell or
figure out a cheap way to tell and
starting from there because once you
want you start thinking like that then
you need less people then you need less
you know you don't need a giant company
go here's a money you know you don't
need to do a Kickstarter $50,000
campaign and shrank I think it trains
your head as a book because I write it I
direct it I produce it edit it i
fundraise for it I promote it I cast it
so if I'm doing all those things and I
know that I'm doing it without having to
go is this person okay for you I'm gonna
cast this person is that person okay to
a company to a producer to someone who's
overseeing it focus on the freedom focus
on what you the story you want to tell
and the best way that you can tell it
would be my advice and not everybody
agrees with that it's probably
antithetical to marketing to finding a
sponsor but if your story is really good
and your audience knows like the vampire
mob audience knows how we make this show
they've seen oh shoot the show I talked
on Twitter about making the show I blog
about it so they know that we are just
just a few people with cameras shooting
in somebody's kitchen or stealing shots
out in the street or whatever we're
doing and that becomes the personality
of the show it becomes for lack of a
better term the brand of the show that
we like these indie people that were
just like it let's just go do this
and go do it so this idea that you have
that you should not give a webseries
towards some void that's currently not
been filled out there is that embraced
by other filmmakers or webseries
directors and have you met any
opposition yes I've been asked if I was
a hobby because I didn't talk about
demographics and sponsorship I talked
about story and audience and working
with Emmy winners and Tony winners and
you know I I think part of the problem
with the webseries community is that a
lot of people want to be pioneers and
veterans and this is not old enough to
have veterans this has not been I wrote
for web series in 2004 monomania in San
Francisco paid gig there multiple
syndication to newspapers so a newspaper
or legal uh Washington Post would buy
syndication rights to their animated
show to have honor works
his content and that would be the place
that I would show up and that was the
redness dream so they go forward to fly
me from LA to San Francisco pitch come
back and right then in 2007 I directed
one show and produced another show for
super-deluxe which was a Cyrillic scone
which was turner entertainment so they
had lots and lots of money and it was
great
they paid us all it was great I am NOT a
bedroom because this hasn't been around
long enough for there to be veterans
we're not pioneering an industry we're
just storytellers that are posting stuff
online that's been going on since the
mid 90s what's changed his behavior is
the acceptance that I'm going to watch a
television show on my phone for 45
minutes while I'm at the airport
that wasn't a value that was held by
humanity that wasn't people didn't think
login I'll just go watch on Hulu Oh
Netflix has now an original series you
can only watch it on Netflix they're
going to make more like that has been
where this is all headed so this idea of
a drama should be a 4-minute episode a
comedy should be no longer than a
three-minute episode and it needs to
have something that gun could sponsor
building stories up from the
demographics to me is just like here's
the keys of the kingdom now do you want
to use any of them or do you want to act
an emulate an industry that has been
storytellers or going on a
century now because the people with the
money get to make the decisions and the
people who tell the stories don't here
you are you have everything all you need
is money and figure out some way
to do it that's all you need to do why
are you thinking about what who could
sponsor this cuz you need money well how
can we make it cheaper so we don't need
a sponsor so I can tell the story I want
so I can not have to lead a three-minute
thing because the people who say don't
make it longer than three minutes don't
make it longer than five minutes
you know they're looking at the
analytics on YouTube gone well when do
we lose the audience where do they fall
up are you are you trying to create a
viral video cuz now you're wasting your
time
no one can create a viral video if you
look at the history viral videos
something happens it's not that that
just made their put online and they go
viral something happen refers to as
something mentions it there's a number
of blogs even things that are in the
news now that happened a month ago now
they're a big viral thing you can't make
it happen so why are you pretending you
can why are you pretending to be a
pretty sure that walks around with my
well here's all my demographics and
here's my business plan and really is
that way is that what you're dreaming
about when you were kid is that what
you're wanting to do when you want to
haul it you know what I'd love to
tell stories and make movies and
would that be great which it was some
way I could it up
what if I started to make all my stories
based on demographics and pleasing the
sponsorship you're trying to get a
company to say yes why the would
you do that now this has never happened
in history ever we've never been here
before
why it up with all the
that's been filmmakers from you
know the indie thing just go from 87 to
now it's a bit about put it all on a
credit card get in the film festival get
a distributor to go now all those our
houses are gone the money is not there
the festivals are overwhelmed
with projects it doesn't work anymore
and it's great that Kevin Smith has a
giant audience he can find his way it's
great that burns has died knowing he can
find his way the other thing is do you
ever want your own audience how you
gonna get that you know you're gonna
have to do start with one fan and then
you're only gonna have 50 fans just like
everybody else
and you're gonna have to work to build
that up if you want to be your own thing
but if you want to be an employee for
the factory that tells you what to do
that you have to fit in all these
certain little things and do all this
then go do it
enjoy yourself put on your suit
hold up your business degree I just want
to tell stories if that's what you want
to do
here's all the freedom in the world
figure it out
stop acting like everyone else because
you know what everyone else is doing the
same thing they're all trying to figure
out that what shits what girls say about
SH what this says but it's such a
waste of time like you can finally get
around all the why would you
make the part of the process it
doesn't need to be and that's what bugs
the crap out of the webseries world it's
just too many people on a picture on the
red carpet with a step-and-repeat banner
behind them too many people want another
award another award another one gives a
about all that stuff yeah it helps
me marketing so just talking to your
audience every day about your story
guess what they want to hear about they
want to hear you talking about your
story that's more interesting to them
not all of them not everybody kept some
people just want to go watch something
go away I don't care who made it I don't
care of this people arms great story
don't other people who made this where
did this come from
who that's and to have those people
that's really cool have to have somebody
in England go I've been going for a
really hard time in my life and I found
your show and it made me laugh and made
me forget about my kid who's sick and
made me forget about being unemployed
I'll take that over in here for
awards a reviewer saying good job
you know to have someone say who is not
part of an industry your story affected
me I'll take that let's talk about how
you develop the tool then you come up
with it from your own inspiration not
who are you gonna target to how many
women between this age you're gonna
watch it right so even though it is a
vampire sure but it was you know vampire
mafia is just - I mean the Mafia thing
is always a fun world bad guys are just
fun and it's it's a fun world and I face
some of it on the state of organized
crime in Boston late eighties after the
FBI
sweep of the patriarchal family through
wiretaps there was a big battle for a
turf essentially like who owned what and
and so I the offspring logic to vampire
mob was that was the world that was the
state of this world and so as I cooked
it it actually the first place vampire
mom was it was a short play that was
performed at the Russell Group theater
in Santa Monica even thing to be doing
for nine years called the LA cafe plays
where the third Sunday of every month
five writers meet at 9 o'clock in the
morning they throw 10 envelopes on the
floor when we picked them up and pull
them out there's two headshots with no
resume that's our cast and we're given a
theme and we have four hours write a
play we're done at one start printing it
goes to the casting director and
assistant director they were her sit
until 7:30 that's the first performance
and then they do another show at 9:00 so
I've written about 26 or seven of those
plays and vampire mark was the first one
and it was one of those things that like
if you take a screenwriting class they
will tell you some teachers will say
well let's take your characters grocery
shopping just to see what they do see
how they interact with the world and the
only time you do that is when you're in
class because no one's gonna do that
well looking great some time doing that
but writing that play really let me know
a bunch of stuff about the character and
even at that point Don had a different
name he was a mafia guy he wasn't a
hitman yet there was some inference but
it was about his character or meeting
the person to become a vampire and it
was something I never wanted to shoot I
wanted to the kind of classic
screenwriting thing come in as late as
possible leave as early as possible on a
scene I wanted to come in before should
and I didn't want all that setup so by
minute three the first episode we
already have with conflict as we already
know a bunch of things so the way I
write and right now I'm writing third
season and I have piles of legal pads
can I just jam I just any no rules
anything that comes into my head about
any character any line any scene and I
just start writing these little things
down and when I wrote the second season
I went to the first season legal pad
stuff that I have written and there was
one little spoiler there's one little
thing that I had that Dom the main
character was a hit man had killed
another character's father and she
didn't know it and that was always
something that was in the biography I
think so only I knew that nobody else
knew that but it was in those notes and
in looking through essentially the
character bios I mean I don't get that I
write kind of like who they are what are
they about what do they want that kind
of thing but once I know enough about
the characters then I can go well here's
what this character wants and here's
what this character wants in this world
what's to stop each of these characters
from getting what they want and that's
when plot and all the other stuff for me
comes about so it's really like if
you're a painter
maybe you sketch and you kind of figure
stuff out first and then you start
hitting the canvas for me the legal pads
are just play pure play it's a
playground write anything you want I
write stuff I want an abusing I write
stuff that I do are right out hole
scenes sometimes I'll just bullet stuff
and then once I have it cooking I sort
of have my rules for webseries I have to
try to have three locations per episode
I try to
and with some kind of conflict which is
pretty classic episodic writing that you
what happens next episode like you want
to end at a point that won't make you
think well I want to watch them except
so what the hell happened next you won't
that's what I want and I always write
each episode as an individual file I
never write the whole script I write
episode 1 is one file ever 8 episode 2
and they never come together until I
have them all written part of that is a
complete psychology trick because I'm
not writing a long script so bring these
little things shooting these little
things and then when you put them all
together wow that's a lot of and
the first season was a 33 page the
second season was an 82 page script when
they were put all together and I write
very sparse lots of light and and I will
in post-production I'll cut stuff out I
have cut lines out I've rearranged stuff
I now understand much more about getting
rewritten having written and shot stuff
but it's those are kind of my
structurally my rules so then what I'll
do is I'll have episode 1 I'll have a 1
2 3 those are the three kind of main
story points of each episode like I try
to have like you know Don finds out the
Frank gets out of jail in this episode
of his wife has this reaction to this
and then once I have a bare-bones and I
know where it's going down sit down and
and actually write this fruit so I kind
of like do the freeform Jam on a legal
pad kind of cook the characters cook the
story come up with some ideas and then
give a little structure to each episode
so a very loose outline like one
sentence and then that gives me enough
play because I don't want to have
everything so planned out
happen when I'm writing and then I'll
sit down and actually write the dialogue
and write the scenes and because I know
where I'm going I know that I need to
end by this so it makes me recognize you
know I can't write a five-page scene
because I don't that kind of time with
season three so far the episodes are
going to be a little do you write at
home do you find yourself getting too
distracted there do you go to the coffee
shop do you know I'm not I'm not I tried
to be a coffee shop writer um I always
need to write on a laptop some of that
is pure cycle life it's like I'm just a
little laptop there's just something
about the Sun go desk mm-hmm
seems like let me do a sprint champ yes
just something about it doesn't seem it
just seems closer to God like
handwriting and the laptop anywhere in
bed on the couch if I do if I'm in a
public when I write cafe plays I'm in a
we all needed a cafe to write it at the
background Broadway on Broadway in Santa
Monica I have had phones on and I always
listen to music that I know really well
and I always sent to Fats Waller I would
know a lot of Pat's of all over when I
write because it occupies the part of my
brain that can think of something to do
other than writing I find that it's just
like that part of my brain that's like
okay we should go for a walk maybe what
about another cup of coffee instead it's
just like that's occupied and I'm just
writing and and it creates this little
fantasy world and that's the way I look
at writing it's like I don't believe in
writer's block it doesn't exist it's in
it's just some ideas take a
little longer but to have this kind of
I'm just playing it's all play like it's
got to be fun it's not fun why am i
doing I'm writing oh who wants to do
that I'm not getting paid it's gonna
take everything out of me when I shoot
this I'm playing I'm wrecked this is
gonna be so much fun for these actors
that's the other thing to keep in mind
is like I keep the actors in mind when
I'm writing like because I've paid money
to sag for some reason I don't act
anymore but I have acted it's so much
fun to be handed something and go haul
this it's gotta be so much fun to do
because when I'm writing it it's the
same thing oh so much fun to do so that
those are sort of my loose - even if I'm
writing a feature it's the same it's the
same process it's just a different
structure but it's got to be fun can you
talk about your casting process how are
you approaching actors are you reaching
out to people's managers or agents I
love to cast I love to write the script
knowing who the actor is are with the 21
actress we have for season two I think
we had 12 of them cast while I was
writing the way I approach actors who
were out of my league let's like
Marshall Wallace and he went her on the
Bob Newhart show on The Simpsons I acted
with her and kind of a pilot
presentation thing a long time ago we
had mutual friends who were how I ended
up there and when I was writing the
mother-in-law part
it's another screenwriting trick that if
you cast even if you were never going to
get these people if you cast your roles
even though you're writing a spec
feature but you cast them with the
actors who you imagine playing these
roles it at least for me and I think for
a lot of other writers to hear that
voice makes the dialogue better makes
the writing better and because you
already you're not it's not just words
because because the classic
screenwriting exercises to room remove
all the character names and you should
give a total care who's character that
is just by the dialogue and I think part
of the product making that process is
casting but with Marshall Wallace in the
back of my mind when I was writing
season one was maybe I could get Marcia
Wallace and then after it was done like
I guess I should go ask Marcia Wallace
and working on another web series super
deluxe series called power loafing that
was written by Mike up churches of Emmy
award-winner we're on the Chris Rock
Show he had Neil Patrick Harris come in
as a guest spot and the way they pitched
it to Neil was we need you for four
hours and and we had him in and out
exactly four hours know plenty of
breathing room meal time no rush rush
but four hours and so when I gotten
tough with Marcia I said look I've
written this thing kind of written it
with you in mind would you take a look
at this so she looked at the script and
she said I usually don't do this kind of
stuff but I love this part this is
really funny
and I say I only need you for four hours
because she thinks I'm lying because
every filmmaker is gonna go over
everybody goes over everybody goes along
nobody makes their day when they talk
about four hours so when she came in we
got her in and out four hours Chris
Mulkey on Boardwalk Empire than on Twin
Peaks Chris I need you for four hours
got him in and out four hours Kirsten
banks not same thing so once you've done
it a few times then when you approach
people for season two and I say I said
to Marcia I'm gonna do for eight hours
she believes me she already knows how we
do
we didn't have a casting director ever
we did talk to a couple of casting
directors for one part we chased a big
fish for a long time that we didn't get
a great thing to do is go see and sound
ridiculous but go see theater in LA was
a million theatre companies as a million
black boxes because you can find actors
and watching them work like I cast some
people I told them you have it you have
a part I just want you to come in and
read for two parts I'm not going I'm not
saying you are not I'm saying you were
in this project I just don't know which
one you're gonna be I did that with some
some roles but almost everybody
I'd never have auditions for any of the
parts almost everyone was cast out of
people I'd seen his stage at the rustman
theater some John Colella
who was the lead and co-producer on the
show he had been directed by Ray Allen
and italian-american reconciliation and
answer no so he approached her and she
had already seen the show at the
premiere which we had at the Ruskin so
she saw season one and she knew kind of
what we were up to so it was a lot
easier to get a Tony winning award after
who's been on The Sopranos and a million
other things so I think that's one thing
if you want to get a name actor and can
find some other way other than through
an agent or manager that helps but also
it just casting in general see some
plays try see plays with maybe larger
casts definitely the cafe plays if
you're in Los Angeles at the rust group
theater you can see you know ten actors
they're doing completely different
things in one night I think that's a big
thing and then pre-production like I
said I try to write to a location you
know so like John um john cleland rainey
hall or married in real life and their
real kitchen and the show is the real
kitchen real life that was easy
boom don't
their dog Shiloh is the dog in the show
so that was easy because bring the dog
and we're gonna shoot with the dog a
friend of mine lives in a castle and the
hills and I had already written the
scene with Chris Mulkey and shushie's we
worked on a project together and she was
like would you like to shoot in my house
and I was like she's like I've been a
castle and I'm like mean you live in a
castle and the government looks like a
castle there was like a 25-foot stone
tunnel like completely around and and so
Chris Mulkey he was selling blood out of
a castle somebody else said hey if you
need any cars I have a bunch of cars and
I'm like what kind of cars do you like I
have a Bentley a Maserati a couple of
jaguars a Ferrari and I'm like I'll take
the Bentley and just drop that into the
scene a really good thing to watch if
you haven't seen Christopher Nolan's
Swart well slightly shortened feature
called following the audio commentary on
that is like a film school because that
was he said his make the main characters
apartment was that actor's apartment he
would shoot up from rooftop of the
actors on the street with them laughed
because you don't need a permit if
you're up on the roof
shooting down to them on the street so
once you start thinking like that I
think it helps with pre-production I
think it helps with writing tried it
when I'm writing I'm like how am I gonna
shoot this like I just wrote a scene
there were only two locations I didn't
have which we found God while we were
poor we're in production always a little
dangerous but there was there's one
thing that I've written now that I'm I'm
like I don't know where I'm gonna shoot
that so I'm already I'm not even done
with the script and pre-production is
essentially already started because I
already know there's one location I
don't
all the other locations I have so far
and other ones I can see where they're
gonna be
but that's try to think of all your
friends where they live their yards
their garages their gyms their they have
a friend there's a restaurant one of
those restaurants ours all that kind of
stuff if you can it's early in the
writing process is you can start
pre-production for that kind of stuff it
will make your life so much easier
because if I wrote it's Anna Castle now
I have to go find a castle if I just
write I don't really know where this is
and somebody says hey do you want to
write the castle exterior of Castle doom
we're in a castle so I think that's a
big part of it and the other thing for
pre-production the way I approach
shooting is I hate the mockumentary
thing which is what we are to some
extent it was a way to introduce the
story and break it but it's also an
approach to shooting I shoot three
cameras running at all times as much as
I can because it's coverage it's fast I
can get my reverses I can pick up stuff
that if I was just doing single that
single it makes continuity so much
easier and it makes shooting a lot
easier because if I can light 360 and
I've got two or three cameras running
then I don't need to do a setup for this
reverse and setup for this it speeds up
the whole process and but to try to
shoot something that is visually
appealing like watch stuff that you
liked even if you don't like the movie
or the TV show and you like what it
looks like look at it really look at
what is this frame where where are they
cutting just to kind of get that stuff
in your head for me because we don't I
don't do the proper director photography
I don't we just kind of draw up cameras
and I go how about this and this you got
this this and this good let go who's
been out of time and real basic lighting
and don't try not to write something
right like we shot an action thing and
Jan Brian and Dan Speaker of I
choreographers came in and helped us
kill a couple of guys without killing a
couple guys but I wrote it so I knew I
could shoot it without any help like I
try not to write something that is so
far out of my ability that I have no
idea how to shoot it unless I absolutely
have to because that's another part of
pre-production if you can just keep
stuff I know where this location is I
know we can get this this actor I've
already have in my head all those things
as you're cooking it it all sort of
becomes one process and pre-production
can be less of it the script is done now
let me go find every one of these
locations now let me cast every one of
these parts if I already have people in
my head and locations in my head that I
think we're attainable or no or
attainable they will make all
pre-production and everything so much
easier what's your plan for getting to
the post-production process the editing
the importing footage deciding on how to
categorize things once you get into
Final Cut Pro the post-production I am
of the philosophy that if you can learn
to do as many things in this whole
process so I had never shot with a 5d
before season 2 so I learned about the
camera and then I had to learn about the
post because we shot the first season on
a DX 2100 and mm of a standard
definition to old-school video where
you're you know plugging the camera in
and zipping and capturing little chunks
of video which took forever
but with this process where we're
shooting three camera missed all the
time so then that has to get transcoded
then all that sound has to be synced
using these pluralize that cut on Final
Cut dr7 Cut Pro 7 long vodka and I do
all the cutting I do all the sound I do
all color alright nobody else touches I
leave with the cars and no one sees
anything until it's on YouTube
so it's
what I think that you save in time like
I don't know an editor who would work
for the money that we have which was
nothing to cut 82 pages with this much
work some people like the idea of a
director and the editor being separate I
think that the that because I cut it and
I'm directing it and we don't have a DP
99% of the time that when we shot a
dinner scene for six and I can tell one
operator get this another operator can
you get that I'm going to get this then
I in my head I'm sitting in front of
Final Cut Pro going okay so I have this
I have this I have this
so I'm good okay go as opposed to I
don't know what the editor is gonna want
let's cover the out of this thing
it's such a waste of time so I I know
which I need to get this I know what I
have to pick up because I know how to
cut so if I know how to edit then it's
one less job I think it makes me a
faster director it makes me a better
director it makes me a better director
of photography when I'm playing that
game and it makes it easier for me to
explain to the people I'm working with
we're shooting what what I need and also
I can just sit there in my head and go
okay so I thought thought thought
thought thought thought okay good go
with the fight scene that we had I had a
page and a half of inserts because I
needed to kill people and have guns and
cross bows and arrows and none of we had
no live fire nothing with blanks we
didn't do any of that so I I looked
through the script and I go okay I'm
gonna need that write that down
that or that and then you end up with a
shop list and then it's going through
and making sure do I have everything I
need and that makes the post-production
do I have room tone
you know I monitor what the boom
operator is doing so I have headphones
on while I'm operating a camera and I
can hear the mic is often needed by
something picked up sometimes I'll grab
some wild sound of a door creaking
there's something else that maybe I
think I can use because I also mix all
the sound and I to the color correction
so all of that makes a lot more work and
I would say if you're gonna cut your own
stuff it just it's gonna I don't know
how much time it's gonna take cause I
don't know how fast you are but if you
can learn how to operate a camera and
you can learn how to edit and you can
direct you can be so much cheaper you
can be so much faster and even if you
know a little bit about it and you are
working with another editor you can at
least say look you know if we go from
this shot to this insert to this that's
what I'm thinking and you never cut
before where you don't know kind of what
that brain it's like you focus your
brain on how that works once you have
all that stuff in your head it the more
you know essentially the more you know
about the whole process the better
you're gonna be and I think it's worth
it you know to learn how to edit if you
were director I think it's worth it to
learn how to operate a camera if you're
an editor because even if you are I've
never been a video village tent guy
who's looking at a monitor going like I
wanna write
the actor with the camera I want to be
right in the middle of it I want to see
like I know when the shot go I get made
fun of because I always say cut very
nice some years ago girls are very nice
cuz that's that's my gut reaction like I
saw it go through I'm like very nice
that's it we got it
next moving on or let's do another tape
better want this I it's hard it takes a
lot of time and again it goes back to
make a story you love because when it's
1 o'clock in the morning and you're sick
to death of looking at these
shots and you can't figure out how am I
gonna get from this to this I love this
story I'll figure it out that's opposed
to oh boy they're gonna find Bowl bows
because of this that's a hard thing to
keep motivated about I think but yeah
learn the cut no matter what learn to
cut in terms of marketing promotion how
do you interact with your quote audience
I think that's as important as anything
at this point I think if you're a
director like me or an indie director
you don't have a big resume nobody knows
who the hell you are to get on Twitter
to start talking to people talking about
your story talking about the making of
your story is part of your job if you if
you if you want to be one of those
people they're just like well I make
films and then people watch them and
then I'm gonna go make more films
you're just making mistake and you're
kind of a dick because if you're not
talking to your audience at this point
in history you're losing out hey I'm a
gigantic opportunity like didn't you
want to tell stories to people who the
do you think those people aren't
they're your audience they're on Twitter
they'll say hi you can say hi to them
that's important and also keep in mind
Kevin Smith has this giant audience and
Edward Burns has the giant audience that
they've been building for pushing 20
years 15 years they started somewhere
so we vampire my best 4000 something
followers we started with zero I talked
to people all over the world every
single day it's part of the job it's
Purdue I do and I also really like
talking to people all over the world
it's really interesting to you know say
good night good morning when the time
zones or whatever they are to hear what
so many in South Africa thinks of your
show or Australia Romania UK Germany
Italy I've had audience members help
translate the show into French the whole
first season is in French and German
because people volunteer to translate it
people help me do closed captioning the
thing with having doing stuff online now
if you're if you're not on Twitter and
Facebook it's I think it's part of the
job and I think that if you are talking
you're I don't I say audience member
more than fans because it changes the
dynamic because they just watch the show
they're not fans they just watch the
show they like what you do
hearing what they like why they like it
hearing the responses now that I'm
writing other seasons hearing who they'd
like to see more of I'm not saying that
they tell me what to do and I go do it
but hearing like they wanted to see more
of Kyle on the dog from the first season
in the second season so we had more of
child that was something that was
definitely for the audience but to have
again to have people say your show
affected my life or entertain me or help
me go through a hard time that's the
only way you're going to hear that and
it's not that test group audience thing
is it's you're a human being of tell
stories they're human beings who do
whatever they do and enjoy your story
why not talk why would you not talk to
those people I think it's just it's a
huge missed opportunity and an even if
you are if you're an any person who's
looking to go
whatever having an audience doing
whatever you're doing is always good why
would that ever be bad and yes it takes
time but if you're not investing that
time then I don't know
then who watches your show because you
know I only make the story part of the
year the rest of the time I don't have
anything to talk about we're talking
about the weather and coffee and the
holidays whatever comes up but you begin
to like I now like no needs of people's
kids and who has kids and and that kind
of thing in it it becomes part of your
life and part of the process and you
know beyond just I have a new show look
at it you can only do that so much you
can only go look at me please retweet
please retweet look at this look at this
look at this look at this look at this
No shut up you've been saying the same
thing over and over and over again part
of its you know part of its kind of like
if you're an author and you do a book
signing it's like you're doing a book
signing all the time seven days a week
you're always talking to people you're
always interacting with people and
building an audience from zero to like I
said we're now at 4,000 followers
whatever that translates enter into
views or fundraising and that's the
other part of it if you're not on
Twitter and you want to fundraise
something you're not going to succeed
unless you have some really famous
person that's just going to spike the
interest of that it's just hard work and
and I think most of its done on Twitter
more so than Facebook I know sometimes
you send out e-mail newsletter up ideas
which is great and do you find that that
people also respond to that as well
since it seems like more people on
Facebook and Twitter now I find more
from Twitter than anything yes
more than Facebook and more than email
yeah the emails I don't do too often
because it just feels spammy but even
looking at the you know the report you
get the response to it is not that huge
I mean it's just a little kind of let
people
when something big happens as the way I
wear something little happens or just
keeping people up to date but Twitter is
really its and it's very you know it's
not even official as a blog it's almost
throwaway it's almost when you type it
and goes away and it disappears into the
thumb of Twitter but yeah I think it's
Twitter's the most important part I
think at least now that'll change
remember MySpace and Friendster hmm yeah
yeah underestimate me
so you're talking earlier about Google
TV and where you were or where experts
to envision in about four years so I
think it's it's um when you look at
what's going on with Netflix and Hulu
where they're starting to make their own
shows and YouTube's dropping 150 million
dollars into YouTube or Google into
YouTube channels of all the same company
I think what is happening with the
ability to stream things on your
television again with the behavior of
like I watch a lot of TV on Hulu I
rarely watch live television ever I
absolutely don't even watch my actual
television that often anymore that is
that's a behavioral thing that changes
there's lots of Internet connected TVs
out there that are not connected to the
Internet that's going to change now that
you can strain with a ps3 with a
Playstation with a Xbox a TiVo blu-ray
player
now that Netflix has shows that you can
only see on Netflix and they're bringing
Arrested Development back and they're
shooting David Fincher's House of games
and our house of cards who lose has
battleground
and a couple other shows the the
behavioral reality of appointment
television is dying it's only really the
American titles and that sort of thing
where this is all going is that there
will be no more networks in the classic
sense of the word in terms of your brain
because it's like the TiVo once you
start doing TiVo then it was like well
you just put your own network together
right now it's just a tsunami of content
that is just coming towards everyone and
more and more videos are getting
uploaded now it's gonna be about quality
it's going to be about what people like
but the reality of sitting down or
watching a television show at a certain
time is over
even with Netflix they put out
Lillehammer which is a show they made
with Norwegian television they put all
eight episode they put all seasoned up
in one day because more television is
Washington Netflix right now than movies
so they already know this binge viewing
this idea of like sitting down with all
of Sons of Anarchy or all of Mad Men and
just watching episode after episode that
is a behavioral thing that's happening
so where this all ends up is I think for
an independent storyteller
if Hulu or Netflix puts a show on the
Internet and so we can stream it to
their television and you put a story on
YouTube and they can stream it to their
television what is the difference
between you and Netflix and Hulu nothing
it's just a Babylonian marketing that's
all they have I mean it's that's a nice
thing to have but the reality is that's
sort of like they're the Cineplex you
know we're still the indie theatre down
the street that has the shitty popcorn
but we're both on the Internet
we're both can stream to televisions so
right now in terms of the future there's
no difference between me and what
they're doing other than their giant
machine with money and marketing and and
more production value but the reality of
all this is that I can now like when you
made a film you'd have to go to a
festival get a distributor get it to a
theater now you can just put it on the
Internet and more people see stuff on
the
internets and more movies on their
television and straining than the not so
why wouldn't why wouldn't you do that I
think that's where the future is it's
gonna be a mess it's gonna be archaic
it's gonna be hard to figure out where
stuff is that's that's the next thing
and maybe Google TV will play a part in
helping people find things but
everything's gonna be on the internet
independent stories Network stories
there will be no more okay there's no
need for cable it's it already Authority
building a cable station on YouTube that
has more channels than any cable system
that exists now so that's already
happening now it's really just about the
audience's behavior catching up to the
technology's ability it's already there
it's just the mindset of I'm gonna watch
that on my computer or I'm gonna stream
that to my television what would you see
is the timeframe will be fully
integrated into you I don't know I I
don't know it it's not gonna be probably
this year next year I think it's more
about you know it probably took see
YouTube starts at 5:06 took maybe four
years to get people to start watching
stuff on hulu and netflix so maybe three
four years something like that